ultimate factories are building the
ultimate Corvette zo6 the goal keep
Corvettes classic design while pushing
it to record-breaking top speeds faster
than ever before
in pure speed and horsepower this
$71,000 Corvette rivals exotic foreign
cars like the Ferrari f430 and the
Lamborghini Gallardo so light this Grand
Touring mega machine handles like a race
car so powerful it goes from zero to 60
in four seconds so fast
it pushes nearly 200 miles an hour all
backed by a custom Corvette engine on
steroids for engineers it was a tough
challenge
for a chassis frame worthy of a zo6
Chevy hired the ultimate chassis
manufacturer specialists their solution
a thick aluminum skeleton called a space
frame durable moldable and lightweight
while a standard Corvette space frames
made from steel the zo6 is aluminum
frames 30% lighter shedding an
incredible 136 pounds and lighter equals
faster now that skeleton is ready for
some skin the body panels that give the
Corvette its unmistakable look most cars
have raw metal body panels added before
the car is painted but the Corvettes
body panels aren't steel they're
lightweight fiberglass now it's time to
build the most powerful engine ever put
in a GM passenger car almost everything
is unique about the LS 7 engine and is
the O 6 everything about the way it
breeze the way the air flows through the
engine the size of the valves the
material used it's extremely efficient
and it's really the heart of the co 6
most modern engines are put together on
an assembly line but not the LS 7 it's
hand-built like a racecar engine by one
technician who hand assembles it a
turntable device helps with the monster
engine assembly the operator uses a
wheel to rotate the engine base while
different components are added on this
is the most important part of this
engine the part that we all love the
most is when we put our name on it
in an ordinary car an engine is directly
attached to a transmission but the
Corvette zo6 is no ordinary car it's one
of the fastest sports cars in the world
and it must have world-class handling to
match its world-class speed one key to
perfect handling perfect weight
distribution over the front and rear
axis the Corvette zo6 waste just 3162
pounds
the massive ls7 engine is lightweight at
450 pounds but in a featherweight car
like the Corvette it's still like a boat
anchor weighing down the front of the
car a car heavy in the front will steer
poorly and plow into turns something you
don't want in a sports car or a LeMond
racer Chevy's solution remove the heavy
transmission to the back of the car to
balance out the weight well this is what
they call the Turk tube and it bolts up
directly into the bell housing and into
the motor and this is what transfers the
power to the transmission in the back
end yeah that's the unique design what
it does it aids in the weight
distribution of the car now the zo6 is
ready for one more race car edition a
dry sump oil system a typical car uses
an oil pan to circulate oil throughout
the engine but the zo6 in the c6 our
race car used something different a
separate reservoir outside of the engine
that pumps oil through the engine of
course a key component of handling
performance is the wheel and tire
combination the zo6 features Corvettes
largest wheel and tire combination ever
the front 10 spoke wheels are 18 inches
in diameter and nine and a half inches
deep that is one heck of a wide tire
that's a lot of traction
as the frogs are what you say the back
the rear wheels are even larger they're
19 inches in diameter and 12 inches deep
with the tires and wheels in place the
Corvette factory brings the car to life
for the first time but before it hits
the road it hits the testing station the
dynamic vehicle test zeroes in on the
wheel and tire pressure and how it
handles at 70 miles per hour
this zo6 test perfect and is ready to
leave the ultimate Corvette factory from
a bare aluminum space frame to a fully
loaded chassis the zo6 is now a
world-class sports car ready for the
open road